Bene, buonasera, grazie. Dunque, quest'anno, come sapete, il tema dei nostri tre incontri
è, potremmo dire, tutto quello che credevamo di sapere sul medioevo e che invece non è
vero. È il tema di un periodo storico, il medioevo, che tutti abbiamo in mente, che
tutti crediamo di poter immaginare, a cui pensiamo di poter attribuire un'infinità
di immagini, di episodi, di avvenimenti, di situazioni, e che però è un periodo che
è stato, in realtà, inventato dopo, in gran parte. Non vi sto dicendo che Carlo Magno
non è esistito, ma che tante cose che noi diamo per scontate quando si parla di medioevo,
quando uno va a vedere, invece, sono molto più leggendarie che non autentiche. Ad
direi vero, quello di cui parliamo stasera è, forse, come dire, la cosa meno sensazionale,
in questo senso, che quando ho cominciato a raccontare agli amici gli argomenti di cui
pensavo di parlare qui quest'anno, ho visto che quando gli dicevo, guarda che lo use
prima in hoctis, oppure l'idea della terra piatta, non è mica detto che davvero nel
medioevo. Ecco, vedevo che rimanevano più stupiti. Il tema di cui parliamo stasera,
le paure dell'anno mille, invece, è forse un pochino più passato di moda. Non tutti
forse siamo convinti che ci fossero quelle paure, perfino su internet, quando uno va
a vedere, e cerchi paure, terrori dell'anno mille, nella maggior parte dei siti, in realtà
trovi la leggenda delle paure dell'anno mille. Quindi forse sfondo una porta aperta,
e però credo che si possa essere interessante lo stesso, andare a vedere come è stata costruita
a un certo punto un'immagine del medioevo, che si rivela completamente leggendaria,
completamente inventata, e a cui invece per molto tempo gli eruditi, gli studiosi hanno
creduto, hanno creduto e come. Proprio perché dicevo che è una vecchia storia, magari
un po' passata di moda, ricordiamolo rapidamente di cosa sto parlando. Le paure dell'anno
mille non si riferiscono genericamente al fatto che nel medioevo ci fossero dei movimenti
ogni tanto che annunciavano la prossima fine del mondo. Non si riferiscono solo al fatto
che per i cristiani del medioevo il problema di quando arriverà alla fine del mondo fosse
un problema sentito, quello non è in discussione. Quando si parla dei terrori dell'anno mille
ci si riferisceReally ha un'immagine ben precisa, all'idea che nel medioevo pensavano
che il mondo sarebbe finito nell'anno mille. Quindi quando l'anno mille ha cominciato a
avvicinarsi, perché voi capite che queste cose finché le dici nell'anno 750, ma quando l'anno
mille ha cominciato a avvicinarsi, secondo questo racconto, la gente ha avuto paura sul serio.
E negli ultimi anni, prima dell'anno mille, il mondo si è quasi fermato, non aveva più senso
mettersi e darsi da fare, fondare una famiglia, lavorare. Tanto il mondo finisce mandate, tra 3 anni,
tra due, l'anno prossimo finisce brigade, e negli ultimi mesi dell'anno 999 il mondo si è davvero
fermato. Secondo questa storia che troviamo contata da tanti studiosi, da tanti dotti della
nostra epoca dell'ottocento, del novecento ancora. Negli ultimi mesi dell'anno novecento
e noventa nove la gente si affollava nelle chiese a pregare e piangere sperando di salvarsi
perché appena fosse finito l'anno novecento e noventa nove finiva il mondo. Ecco io adesso
ve l'ho detta con parole mie ma in realtà vorrei ricordare quanto profondamente era sentito
questo tema in particolare nella cultura dell'ottocento e che impatto romantico aveva
questa immagine di un intero mondo piegato dal terrore perché aspetta la fine del mondo.
Vi leggo poche righe di un brano del Carducci. Carducci scrive questo nel primo dei suoi
discorsi sullo svolgimento della letteratura nazionale. È una storia della letteratura
italiana perché Carducci si preoccupa dei terrore dell'anno mille. Ne parleremo. Intanto sentiamo
Carducci che era uno che sapeva scrivere. Vimmaginate il levare del sole nel primo giorno
dell'anno mille. Questo fatto di tutte le mattine ricordate che fu quasi miracolo, fu
promessa di vita nuova per le generazioni uscenti dal secolo decimo e poi dice Carducci i terrori
che si erano accumulati per anni e anni e naturalmente anche le ragioni di aver paura,
le epidemie, le carestie, i prodigi. Tutto questo all'avvicinarsi dell'anno mille si coagula
in un'immensa paura collettiva. Sempre Carducci, mille e non più mille, aveva secondo la tradizione
detto Gesù. Dopo mille anni leggevasi nell'apocalipsi Satana sarà disolto. Dopodiché segue appunto
la descrizione delle folle gementi nelle chiesi negli ultimi giorni dell'anno mille,
1999. E poi c'è lo straordinario colpo di scena. Il primo giorno dell'anno mille il sole
sorge e non è successo niente. E che stupore di gioia e che grido salì al cielo dalle
turbe raccolte in gruppi silenziosi intorno a manieri feudali, accosciate e sindiozzanti
nelle chiesi tenebrose e nei chiostri, quando il sole, eterno fonte di luce e di vita, si levò
triomfale la mattina dell'anno mille. Formidabile naturalmente. Carducci è un grande scrittore,
ma queste cose le scrivevano anche i miei colleghi, gli storici nell'ottocento. Giusto per non negarci
niente, due righe da uno storico francese, il Lavallet a lievo di Michelet. Storia dei
francesi, 1844. Traducco alla buona. La credenza nella fine del mondo, credenza che sembrava
giustificata dalle pesti, le fami, le calamità di ogni genere che desolavano l'Europa, provocava
una atonia universale. Tutto era ghiacciato di paura nell'attesa del giorno fatale. Ogni
impresa si era fermata, ogni movimento si era arrestato, non c'era più un'esperanza
né avvenire, si raddoppiava di fervore religioso, con gioia del professore Di Freddi che vedo
qui davanti a me. Ci si accumulava, ci si affollavano i conventi, si donavano i propri
beni alla chiesa e da ogni parte si sentiva questo grido lugubre, la fine del mondo si
avvicina. Bene, abbiamo assodato se non altro un punto, nell'Ottocento erano tutti i convinti
che ci fosse stato questo terrore collettivo che ha bloccato la società europea. Abbiamo
modo di controllare, abbiamo modo di andare a vedere cosa succedeva davvero nell'anno
1999. Eh beh, un po' di fatica sì, andiamo a cercare dei documenti scritti in quell'anno.
Per esempio, cosa faceva il Papa alla fine del 1999? Papa che doveva essere abbastanza
interessato all'argomento evidentemente. Noi abbiamo una bolla papale, pensate che
è fortuna, del 31 dicembre 1999. Il 31 dicembre 1999, Papa Silvestro II conferma i privilegi
di un grande monastero tedesco, il monastero di Fulda. Sono vari privilegi che la sede romana
conferma su richiesta della Bate e il Papa consegna questa bolla datata 31 dicembre 1999
alla Bate di Fulda dicendogli, ti confermo tutti i privilegi del tuo monastero, a te
e ai tuoi successori, a patto che in futuro ogni abate che verrà eletto venga a chiedere
a Roma la conferma della sua elezione. Inoltre, voi in cambio di questi privilegi, monaci
di Fulda, dovete pagare un'offerta ogni anno di 12 denari alla sede romana da pagare
in futuro ogni anno. Almeno questi due non si stavano aspettando la fine del mondo evidentemente.
È vero che Papa Silvestro II era un personaggio speciale, era un grande erudito, un grande
dotto, tanto dotto che qualcuno addirittura lo sospettava anche di un po' di intralazzi
con la magia, si chiamava Gerberto di Oriac prima di diventare Papa, magari lui era un
po' speciale, magari gli sprovveduti e la gente qualunque invece se l'aspettavano questa
fine del mondo. Andiamo a vedere cosa faceva la gente qualunque nel 1999. Tra un po' di
documenti che ho trovato venecito uno a caso, ho cercato fra quelli piemontesi che per me
era più comodo. Siamo a Tortona, in un mese imprecisato del 1999. Due fratelli, uno è un
rete a Delberto, l'altro è un laico e Renzone, sono due piccoli imprenditori, prendono in
affitto delle case e delle terre dei campi dal monastero di San Marziano di Tortona. Prendono
in affitto queste terre con un contratto scritto, cosa che nell'anno 1999 in certe parti d'Europa
non si usava più tanto, perché in molte parti d'Europa andavano più alla buona, un contratto,
uno sputo sul palmo, stretta di mano. In Italia, paese più vicino alle sue radici classiche,
si usava di più andare dal notaio anche per fare un contratto d'affitto. Facevano questo
contratto d'affitto che chiamavano il Libretto, libellus in latino. Questo contratto d'affitto
noi ce l'abbiamo. La Bate dà in affitto queste terre a questi due fratelli per la durata
di, qui vi voglio preparare, nelle nostre campagne fino a un po' di tempo fa era in vigore
la mezzadria. E la mezzadria voi sapete che era un sistema, come dire, in apparenza paritaria
o in realtà molto squilibrato a favore del padrone e normalmente il contratto durava
un anno. Alla fine del raccolto a San Martino il mezzadro consegnava tutto e se il padrone
voleva cacciarlo lo poteva cacciare. L'albero degli zoccoli di Hermano Olmi, tanto per
citare un film che magari molte hanno visto. Nel Medioevo non era così. Nel Medioevo c'erano
poche braccia e uno dei grandi problemi per un proprietario terriero, tanto più per i
monaci che avevano altro a cui pensare che non star sempre dietro ai campi, un grande
problema per i proprietari terrieri era di trovare lavoratori che stessero lì, anzi
se mai di costringerli a stare lì se possibile, anziché cacciarli. Quindi nel Medioevo usavano
contratti a lunga scadenza. Nell'anno 1999 la Bate di San Marziano di Tortona dà inaffitto
queste terre del monastero a questi due fratelli per la durata di 29 anni. A condizione che
dovranno abitarci, coltivarle, non permettere che queste terre vadano in malora e ogni anno
pagheranno al monastero un terzo del grano raccolto e metà del vino. Non solo, fa comodo
al padrone verri lì per 29 anni, ma anche a loro fa comodo una bella garanzia per il
contadino. Dunque la garanzia sta a contratto. Vidiamo queste terre per 29 anni. Se nell'arco
di questi 29 anni qualche mio successore a Bate dovesse cercare di riprendersela, pagherà
la penale di 20 soldi d'argento prevista dal contratto. Dunque anche questi nell'anno
1999 non si aspettavano che il mondo finisse l'anno dopo, evidentemente. Non c'è proprio
nessuno che parla della fine del mondo nell'anno 1999. Alla fine un documento l'ho trovato,
che parla della fine del mondo, ma bisogna vedere in che termini. È un diploma dell'imperatore
ottone terzo. L'imperatore ottone terzo quell'anno è andato a Roma per varie brighe
sue. Arriva a Roma e naturalmente si affolla la gente che gli chiede, si affollano i postulanti,
che gli chiedono donazioni conferme, diplomi, beneficie, così via. Tra l'altro arrivano
i monaci di Farfa. Farfa è un grande monastero naziale. Anche loro hanno dei privilegi naturalmente.
Farfa è un grande monastero imperiale, appartiene all'imperatore, però loro hanno un privilegio
che l'imperatore non lo può regalare a qualcun altro quel monastero. Come invece gli imperatori
facevano volentieri. Hai un vecchio consigliere da premiare che deve andare in pensione, un
tipo importante. Cosa ne fai? Lo nomini abbate di un monastero che va da lì e si goda le
ricchezza di quel monastero. Queste cose ai monaci piacciono poco. I monaci di Farfa
hanno il privilegio, non possono essere dati in questo modo a nessuno. I loro abbate se
lo eleggono loro. L'imperatore ottone terzo dice benissimo, siamo d'accordo. Ve lo concediamo.
Confermiamo questo privilegio, dice l'imperatore, il 3 ottobre 999. Traducco dal latino. Per
cui d'ora in poi, ineterno, mai più nessuno dei nostri successori potrà dare in beneficio
a qualcuno il monastero di Farfa, ma rimanga sempre di proprietà dello Stato, res pubblica.
Se qualche papa in futuro o qualche imperatore nostro successore dovesse invece soggiogare
quel monastero a qualcuno, si ricordi che quando poi verrà Cristo e tutti quanti dovremo
rendergli i nostri conti, dovrà rispondere di aver infranto la mia promessa. Perché Cristo
verrà, la fine del mondo ci sarà e tutti dovremo rendere i conti prima o poi. Ma chiaramente
anche l'imperatore non si aspettava che il mondo finisse l'anno dopo. C'è un altro
modo di controllare. Beh sì, c'erano dei cronisti all'epoca, certo che c'erano persone di
solito studiosi e quindi di solito all'epoca uomini di chiesa, monaci, che a un bel momento
decidevano di mettersi a tavolino e scrivere i grandi avvenimenti a cui assistevano. Magari
anche solo poche righe, magari invece anche di più, anno per anno. Ci sono parecchi cronisti
che hanno vissuto l'anno mille e che scrivono, nel 998 è successo questo e quell'altro,
nel 999 è successo questo, nel 1000 è successo quest'altro, l'imperatore è andato a Roma,
nel 1001 è tornato in Germania e così via. Non c'è nessuno che dica c'era il terrore
dell'anno mille, c'erano le folle, c'erano dei movimenti, penite niente. Dobbiamo pensare
che nel medioevo erano gente così laica e disinvolta che della fine del mondo non
gli importava niente, no evidentemente, l'abbiamo appena visto, della fine del mondo gli importava.
Il problema è quando verrà la fine del mondo. C'è modo di saperlo, torniamo un po' indietro.
Noi l'abbiamo detto, il Carducci dice mille, non più mille ha citato l'Apocalisse, ecco,
andiamo un po' a vedere cosa ne sapevano loro della fine del mondo. Sapevano tutto tra
nella data, sapevano tutto perché c'è il libro dell'Apocalisse che descrive esattamente
come avverrà la fine del mondo. Il libro dell'Apocalisse che è l'ultimo libro canonico
del nuovo testamento attribuito a San Giovanni Evangelista ma probabilmente non è vero. Comunque
è testo antico, fine e primo secolo, un testo totalmente delirante, va detto, visionario che
racconta le cose più straordinarie e che complessivamente si presenta come la descrizione della fine
del mondo. Questa cosa per gli ecclesiastici del Medioeva era molto importante e molto
utile anche. Immaginate un cronista che vuole scrivere la storia universale. Va in biblioteca,
comincia, trova gli storici antichi, i greci, i romani, i cartaginesi, Annibale e così via,
Costantino, il grande imperatore cristiano, i barbari, Carlo Magno. Poi siamo arrivati
adesso al presente, lascio un po' di pagine bianche e poi volendo alla parte finale la
posso già mettere perché si sa già come sarà la fine del mondo. Basta andare a prendere
l'Apocalisse e la descrive, verrà l'Anticristo, commetterà ogni sorta di nefandezza e poi
verrà sconfitto, tornerà a Cristo. L'Apocalisse, come vi dicevo, è un testo visionario e farraginoso
dove si trova di tutto. A un certo punto l'autore dell'Apocalisse comincia a giocare con numero
1.000. Non si capisce tape niente e non è che mi dovete credere, adesso ve lo leggo. Ma
che c'entri l'anno 1.000 o meglio il numero 1.000? Questo è evidente. Apocalisse 20 versetti
1.7. Poi vi dì un angelo che scendeva dal cielo e che aveva la chiave dell'abisso e una
gran catena in mano. Egli prese il dragone, il serpente antico che è il diavolo.
E' satana. E lo leggo per 1.000 anni. Poi lo gettò nell'abisso che chiuse e si gillò
sopra di lui, perché non seducesse più le nazioni finché fossero compiuti i 1.000 anni.
Uno legge questo e dice cosa vorrà dire? Eh, sembrerebbe dire che in certo punto per 1.000
anni satana è reso impotente perché? Perché è venuto Cristo? Certo, saranno 1.000 anni da
quando è venuto Cristo? E poi però allora qua dice che dopo 1.000 anni lo liberano satana.
E subito dopo verrà la fine del mondo. Questa è una linea di ragionamento che è possibile.
E' talmente possibile, se mi permettete una piccola parentesi, che anche oggi, perché
non è che noi oggi ne sappiamo di più che nel medioevo, anche oggi salta fuori ogni
tanto la setta. È vero che succede più facilmente nel Texas protestante che non qui da noi,
ma anche oggi salta fuori ogni tanto la setta che dice guardate che verrà la fine del mondo
e tutti gli adepti donano tutti i loro beni al capo della setta e poi a volte si suicidano
anche tutti quanti insieme. Ecco questi movimenti, queste sette noi come li chiamiamo? Li chiamiamo
movimenti millenaristi. Parliamo di sette millenariste, di millenarismo, quando ci riferiamo
a qualcuno che predica ad avvicinarsi della fine del mondo. Parliamo di millenarismo
perché continuiamo a essere impregnati di queste cose che si leggono nell'apocalisse,
che accosta i mille anni alla fine del mondo. E dunque, all'avvicinarsi dell'anno mille,
c'è stato qualcuno, abbiamo appena visto che nel 1999 non ci pensava più, si era messo
il cuore in pace, ma in quei decenni c'è stato qualcuno che ha fatto questi ragionamenti
sul libro dell'apocalisse e che ha cominciato a dire in giro, preparatevi perché guardate
che nell'anno mille il mondo finisce prende. C'è stato qualcuno? Sì. Noi abbiamo un racconto
preciso. Chi racconta è un monaco, tanto per cambiare, in quest'epoca quasi tutti quelli
che hanno voglia di raccontare storie sono monaci. Si chiama Abone Abbate di Fleurie in
Francia. Abone di Fleurie, grande studioso, grande scrittore, grande intellettuale, uno
che ha letto molto e capisce retrace molto, scrive un libretto nell'anno 998 dedicato al
re di Francia Roberto. Abone di Fleurie dice al re di Francia, guarda che nel tuo regno ci
sono parecchie cose che non vanno, ci sono parecchie cose che andrebbero corrette. Non sta
parlando del fatto che i conti, anziché rendere giustizia, intascano bustarelle, non è di quello
che parla, parla delle credenze, della cultura, di come funziona la chiesa. Dice, guarda che
nel tuo regno ci sono molti errori che vanno corretti. Per esempio ci sono dei chierici che
non sanno bene il credo e quando recitano il credo sbagliano, dovrebbero dire allo spirito
santo procede dal padre e dal figlio, invece dicono procede dal padre, dimenticano il figlio,
questo non va mica bene, va corretto. Ci sono dei chierici che fanno degli sbagli nel calcolare
il calendario liturgico, fanno cominciare l'avvento un giorno prima e anche questo non va bene,
dice Abone, il re deve provvedere. E poi dice Abone, nel tuo regno, in passato, adesso
un po' che non succede, siamo nel 998, ma in passato ogni tanto venivano fuori queste
storie della fine del mondo e bisognava darci un grande affare per tranquillizzare la gente.
Abone dice, io mi ricordo quando era un ragazzino, e si calcola che siamo intorno al 970, quando
era un ragazzino io stesso ho sentito a Parigi, in una chiesa di Parigi, un predicatore che
avvertiva che nell'anno mille sarebbe venuta la fine del mondo. E io, dice Abone, che già da
ragazzino era uno che aveva studiato, io allora mi ricordo che mi sono sforzato di farlo starzitto
e di spiegare a tutti che si sbagliava citando l'apocalisse e il libro di Daniele e il Vangelo
e così via. Poi dice Abone, è venuto fuori quell'altro sbaglio sulla fine del mondo. Mi ricordo
che ai tempi del buon abate Riccardo, e siamo sempre intorno al 970 più o meno, sono arrivate
al nostro monastero delle lettere che dicevano che in Lorena c'era qualcuno che aveva fatto
questo calcolo assurdo, aveva detto, io vi chiedo scusa se vi trascino in queste cose complesse,
ma questa gente viveva di questi ragionamenti e di queste sottigliezze, qualcuno aveva detto
l'anno in cui il venerdì santo coinciderà con l'annunciazione, cioè il 25 marzo, ci sarà la
fine del mondo. Se ci ragioniamo un attimo perché questo? È chiaro, in quell'anno si chiuda un
circolo, l'annunciazione è l'arrivo di Gesù che è ovviamente l'evento più grande della
storia del mondo, l'avenuta di Gesù ai loro occhi. Il venerdì santo è la morte di Gesù,
se un anno le due date coincidono, siccome noi esseri umani siamo in grado di metterci in
testa le cose più folli e di crederci, intorno al 970 c'era qualcuno che andava in giro dicendo,
guardate che ovviamente io sono andato a vedere sul calendario Perpetuo, quando è che c'era stata
l'ultima volta questa coincidenza nel 908, era passato un bel po' di tempo, quando c'è stata
di nuovo questa coincidenza delle venerdì santo con l'annunciazione nel 970, guarda lì, si vede
che l'anno prima qualcuno ha fatto quel calcolo, ma la cosa interessante è che Abbone che ci sta
raccontando questa cosa dice, quando è arrivata questa notizia il buon abbate Riccardo mi ha detto
Abbone, occupatene tu, scrivi tu in Lorena per spiegare che queste sono tutte fregniacce,
non si esprime così tecnicamente ma è chiaro che questo è il senso del discorso e io dice
Abbone ho scritto spiegando quanto fosse folle questo ragionamento, ergo facciamo il punto,
è assodato che l'idea della fine del mondo che arriva ogni tanto girava e che anche associarla
con l'anno mille non era affatto impossibile a qualcuno è venuto in mente, quello che è
assodato che queste cose ogni tanto venivano fuori e che venivano immediatamente messe a tacere,
non avevano nessuna possibilità di espandersi e di circolare perché i pastori provvedevano
immediatamente a fermare questi ragionamenti e nell'anno 998 quando scrive Abbone sono ricordi
di giovinezza ma perché? La battera Riccardo dice ad Abbone queste sono tutte frotte le
scrivi tu perché sono così convinti gli uomini di Chiesa che non funzionano questi calcoli,
che è sbagliato cercare di prevedere quando verrà la fine del mondo ecco il punto è proprio
questo non è che i calcoli non funzionano e che gli uomini di Chiesa del Medioevo sanno che è
sbagliato cercare di prevedere la fine del mondo ed è sbagliato e giudizio universale naturalmente
è sbagliato perché sta scritto nella Bibbia che non si può sapere Matteo 24 36 quanto a quel
giorno e a quell'ora però nessuno lo sa San Paolo prima lettera ai testalonicesi il giorno del Signore
verrà come viene un ladro nella notte cioè non è che si annuncia prima arriva quando non lo sai
quando diranno sempre San Paolo pace e sicurezza allora l'improvviso li colpirà la rovina ergo il
Signore lo ha detto chiaramente io verrò ma voi non potete sapere quando anzi verrò quando
meno ve lo aspettate quel giorno e quell'ora nessuno lo sa e quindi è perfettamente inutile
mettersi a ragionare su queste cose il primo che lo dice chiaramente è un pensatore cristiano
dei primi tempi che avrà un'influenza enorme sul pensiero cristiano medievale e cioè santa
agostino santa agostino ci ragiona su e lo scrive molto chiaramente calcolare i tempi per sapere
quando sarà la fine di questo mondo o l'avvento del signore mi sembra nient'altro che voler sapere
qualcosa che lui stesso il signore ha detto che nessuno può sapere poi fra parentesi c'è anche
un altro piccolo ragionamento che santa agostino che conosce i suoi testi tira fuori subito sta
scritto anche dice perché non sappiamo quando viene ma magari viene l'anno prossimo calma sta
scritto che prima che venga l'antichristo e poi la fine del mondo il vangelo dovrà essere
predicato a tutti i popoli della terra è stato già predicato no perciò non sarà per l'anno prossimo
dunque facciamo anche qui il punto siamo arrivati a dire che tensioni millenaristiche preoccupazioni
per la fine del mondo nell'arco del medioevo di tanto in tanto vengono fuori ma non hanno spazio
per allargarsi perché dall'alto non sono accettate e ve ne faccio un esempio tanto per farvi
vedere come queste cose in realtà capitavano anche spesso è ma come fossero poi circoscrite vi
faccio un esempio parecchio prima dell'anno mille torniamo indietro 847 siamo nell'anno 847 in
germania un analista racconta che ama gonza e saltata fuori una donna che sostiene di prevedere
il futuro una pseudoprofetissa si chiama fiota questa donna sostiene di conoscere la data della
fine del mondo e guarda caso sarà l'anno prossimo lei conosce questa cosa dice il monoco che nessuno
può sapere come se fosse dio che gliela rivelata e la gente anzi non la gente il monaco uso un termine
di significativo i plebei perché queste cose sono soltanto i poveracci che ci possono credere però
di poveracci ce ne tanti questa donna va dicendo che lei lo sa che la fine del mondo sarà l'anno
prossimo e molti plebei le credono e vanno da lei e le portano dei regali chiedendole di pregare per
loro il vescovo di magonza si secca un po la convoca la interroga e viene fuori almeno la donna
dice che questa cosa gliela suggerita un prete suo amico dicendole tu vai in giro a predicare
che l'anno prossimo viene la fine del mondo vedrai la gente quanti regali ci porta e infatti è proprio
successo così il vescovo si consulta con altri vescovi decidono a questa una bella bastonatura
ogni a toglie nessuno la fanno frustare sulla pubblica piazza e poi fuori dai piedi e che non
così più farsi sentire e così viene come dire spento il movimento millenaristico di magonza
dell'anno 847 a questo punto quanto tempo mi sono già giocato be buona parte per nostra fortuna
se voi ricordate da dove siamo partiti noi siamo partiti da gente e non gente da poco ma un
carducci storici accreditati autorevoli del loro tempo che ci hanno detto che negli ultimi mesi e
giorni prima dell'anno mille c'era il terrore collettivo le chiese piazza inutile che ve lo
dicano sembrerebbe assodato che quell'immagine è interamente immaginaria appunto è inventata
non è vero che è successo questo allora però voi capite che si pone allo storico un problema
diverso ma anche è abbastanza interessante se non è mai successo chi è che l'ha inventata questa
storia chi quando perché come possibile al di là dell'angoscia di scoprire che noi storici
possiamo credere e raccontare vedo sempre solo di freddi che ride sotto i baffi ma anche voi
matematici secondo me certe volte comunque noi storici possiamo a me convincerci di cose e
convincere chi ci legge che poi cent'anni dopo si scopre che sono totalmente inventate e non è
piacevole rendersi ne conto dirle verità il rimedio è andare a cercare di capire come è
successo perché almeno se uno capisce tape come succedono queste cose forse si può starci un
po più attenti forse come successa questa storia molti studiose ci sono messi a cercare di ricostruire
la genealogia di questa leggenda dei terrori dell'anno mille ed è saltata fuori proprio proprio
una genealogia nel senso di una serie di autori che si sono uno dopo l'altro copiati
aggiungendo ognuno qualcosina il meccanismo è questo e a volte ci vogliono secoli perché
questo capiti io adesso mi sono chiesto a lungo preparando questa lezione gli faccio tutto l'elenco
oppure lo a brevio ne faccio qualche esempio il primo colpevole è un cronista del medioevo un
monaco che scrive intorno al 1100 cent'anni dopo i fatti è un bravo cronista si chiama si
geberto si geberto di giamblu scrive una cronica ha letto tanti libri ha letto gli analisti dell'anno
mille i quali delle paure non parlava per niente è vero però che nell'anno mille qualche cronista
ha menzionato un terremoto e i terremoti voi capite è un afferserio perché il terremoto è un
segnale vuol dire qualcosa poi si geberto legge le sue fonti e scopre che nel 1002 c'è stata una
cometa e anche la cometa è una cosa seria perché dio non si prende il disturbo di modificare
l'armonia delle stelle se non c'è un motivo molto preciso di mandare un avvertimento agli
uomini si geberto fa due più due e già che c'è semplifica un po terremoto nel mille cometa
nel mille due si geberto dice senti qui qui c'è di mezzo il mille evidentemente quell'anno
era un anno un po speciale si geberto semplifica nell'anno mille ci sono stati un terremoto
una cometa ed è apparsa un serpente nel cielo non dice va detto onore di si geberto di giamblu non
dice e tutti hanno avuto paura della fine del mondo lui si limita a accumulare questi prodigi
e lui stesso un millenarista l'anno mille è passato però l'impressione di quella cifra tonda
continua a funzionare passano altri 70 anni 1170 circa un altro cronista cister cense ghiom godel
che ha letto anche lui i cronisti dell'anno mille degli anni successivi ha scoperto che nell'anno
1010 c'erano state delle visioni carestia ecclissi ce n'è abbastanza ghiom godel scrive nell'anno
1010 ci sono stati tutti questi prodigi e molta gente ha avuto paura che il mondo finisse nelle
sue fonti non c'era questo quelli che erano vissuti nel 1010 gli han detto c'è stata l'eclisse ma
ghiom godel non è mica uno sciocco lo sa cosa pensa la gente quando vede l'eclisse e allora ecco
il primo che parla di un terrore collettivo peccato per noi che lo mette nel 1010 è esasperante ma
è così dopo di che il medioevo continua lungo tutta questa epoca che gli amici di carducci
immaginavano come epoca di credulità e ignoranza non c'è più nessun altro che si sogni di riprendere
questa frasetta sui terrori poi finalmente arriva il rinascimento in quell'epoca illuminata che è
il rinascimento comincia una salta fuori storici che invece ci credono che la gente avesse avuto
paura della fine del mondo salta fuori per esempio il tritemio che pochi di noi giustamente
hanno sentito nominare ma che è un importante umanista tedesco inizio del 500 che nella sua
cronaca anche lui ha letto sigiberto di giamblu e anche lui quindi dice nell'anno mille ci fu
il terremoto e ci fu la cometa e ci furono le visioni e molti si spaventarono temendo che
arrivasse l'ultimo giorno questo non l'ha letto in sigiberto di giamblu ma voi capite come funziona
è un umanista ormai il rinascimento quei poveracci la stava nelle tenebre del medioevo quando hanno
visto tutti quei prodigi figurati se non si sono spaventati si sono spaventati e come
e il tritemio lo scrive e continua così autori su autori riprendono questa chiacchiera e ognuno
ci ricama sopra perché è bello immaginarsi la questa scena è di tutto un mondo che si
ferma per il terrore e mi rendo conto che a dirlo così sembra incredibile perché noi
abbiamo questa ostinata convinzione che quando leggiamo qualcosa è perché l'autore la sa
quella cosa che scrive e quindi è vera e non è assolutamente così si possono scrivere le cose
più stupefacenti e magari l'autore se ne convince anche ma se gli vai a chiedere come fa a bella
siamo stare perché qui prenderei una via ma comunque diventa un luogo comune tutti sanno nel
600 nel 700 nell' 800 che ci sono stati i terrori dell'anno mille va detto che c'è un motivo che li
incoraggia in questa credenza e che noi possiamo anche capirli poveretti perché in realtà specialmente
nel 700 nel 700 comincia una storia grafica scientifica moderna si comincia a rifare la
storia del passato non solo copiando i vecchi cronisti ma confrontando i documenti nel 700
comincia anche la storia delle nazioni moderne delle letterature moderne ora le nazioni moderne
sonnate nel medioevo le letterature nostre sonnate nel medioevo ma prima o dopo l'anno mille
dopo l'anno mille evidentemente tutti abbiamo studiato scuola storia della letteratura italiana
e comincia tutto dopo l'anno mille prima niente e allora i primi studiosi i primi eruditi che si
mettono a fare queste grandi storie di insieme scoprono che il medioevo fin grosso modo all'anno
mille è un'epoca che ha lasciato poche testimonianze succede un poche cose dopo invece esplode tutto
la letteratura provenzale quella francese lingua doil poi quella italiana i trovatori trovi tutto
le grandi cattedrali una grande civiltà che nasce dopo l'anno mille ora tutti questi
eruditi e questi studiosi sanno che nell'anno mille il mondo si era fermato per il terrore e
allora è facilissimo dare quel colpetto che aggiusta tutto l'anno mille diventa il punto
di partenza perché è chiaro che fino all'anno mille la gente era troppo terrorizzato per fare
qualcosa e dopo invece ci sono messi in movimento sembra una barzelletta a dirlo così è stato
sostenuto molto seriamente vicito a un libro importantissimo nella storia della cultura
italiana la bate Bettinelli che nel alla fine del 700 pubblica una prima grande storia della
letteratura e della cultura italiana Bettinelli non è uno qualunque il suo libro è un libro
importantissimo come dire preveggente addirittura basti dire che il libro del Bettinelli uscito nel
1773 si intitola Risorgimento d'Italia negli studi nelle arti e nei costumi dopo il mille e di
conseguenza con cosa comincia il libro del Bettinelli comincia raccontando come che per fortuna il
mondo si è rimesso il movimento e in particolare l'Italia che aveva tante belle cose da fare ma
fino all'anno mille nessuno si muoveva dopo il mille tornossi al quanto alle arti che erano prima
state neglette per una credenza universale che la fine del decimo secolo dovesse essere ancora quella
del mondo notate che il Bettinelli è curiosissimo sgrida gli storici perché dice gli storici ne
parlano poco di questa faccenda e che invece è importantissima dice il Bettinelli perché è
chiaro che quelle paure impedivano che nascesse la letteratura italiana che è quello che interessa
lui e tutto il resto quell'opinione che stesse per finire il mondo non è credibile quanto pregiudicasse
insino all'ultimo giorno del secolo decimo e non è credibile quanto danno toglie se cioè quanto
bene abbia fatto il non aspettato principio del mille l'orror sempre presente d'una prossima
desolazione universale tolsi ad ognuno speranze questa orrenda disperazione non dovette lasciare
altri pensieri eccetera eccetera eccetera vi ero manticcheggiando poi sorge il sore dell'anno
mille ma l'abbia già sentita questa storia e carducci ho cominciato con quello questo che
sto leggendo adesso è Bettinelli un secolo prima ma anche carducci ricordate in che occasione
scrive queste cose io l'ho detto prima ma voi non ve lo ricordate nel suo primo discorso sullo
svolgimento della letteratura nazionale in altre parole c'è un filo diretto preciso chi nel
700 e nell' 800 vuole fare la storia della grandezza italiana della civiltà italiana prima
del mille non trova niente e di conseguenza parte dai terrori e quello che succede in italia
succede in france succede negli altri paesi ognuno per conto suo bene siamo quasi siamo a buon
punto direi c'è ancora un aspetto che io vorrei sottolineare di questa faccenda e che la rende
forse in qualche misura un po più attuale rispetto come dire a tutti questi discorsi di
monaci del dodicesimo secolo che vi ho inflitto nell' 800 sono tutti così convinti dei terrori
dell'anno mille anche perché nell' 800 si stanno combattendo delle battaglie ideologiche molto
precise carducci che abbiamo visto uno dei principali come dire autori di questa leggenda o quelli
che hanno uno di quelli che l'hanno espressa nel modo più romantico più evocativo e carducci è anche
quello dell'inno a satana naturalmente e il carducci delle invettive contro il vaticano
contro la chiesa del suo tempo reazionaria nemica del progresso e il carducci delle poesie che
attaccano il gran prete che in vaticano continua a fare il re e a tagliare le teste degli oppositori
nell' 800 si combatte fra tante battaglie che si combattono si combatte anche una battaglia
della cultura laica progressista scientifica positivista contro la superstizione e la chiesa
dell' 800 è vista da molti di questi che si battono per una cultura laica e progressista è vista come
un nemico non a caso va detto quindi mi permette una piccola parentesi perché le cose vanno
contextualizzate se c'è un anticlericalismo così violento nell' 800 e anche naturalmente perché
la chiesa di allora fa di tutto per farsi considerare come un nemico perché la chiesa di allora è
spaventata dal progresso è cosa che si possa dire tranquillamente perché la chiesa di oggi lui ha
riconosciuto ampiamente la chiesa dell' 800 è terrorizzata dal progresso è terrorizzata dal
liberalismo è terrorizzata dalla scienza combatte il modernismo in tutte le sue forme
scomunica chiude porte è chiaro che dall'altra parte la chiesa è vista come il nemico oscurantista
allora se la chiesa e la religione cristiana sono fonte di superstizioni e di ignoranza
ancor più sarà successo così in quella brutta lontana epoca da cui per fortuna siamo usciti in
cui la chiesa dominava il mondo il medioevo nel medioevo certamente la chiesa così ragionano
carducci e tanti altri e miscelae in francia regnavano davvero le tenebre e allora non c'è da
stupirsi se la gente era così ignorante se la gente era in preda tutte le paure se all'arrivo
dell'anno mille il mondo si è fermato per il terrore ma se da una parte c'è chi combatte
questa battaglia anche dall'altra c'è chi combatte anche dal campo ecclesiastico c'è chi
studia e scrive e pubblica per dire che non è vero niente che la chiesa non era fatto come dire
fautrice di ignoranza e superstizione anzi la chiesa faceva tutt'altro e allora i primi che dicono ma
questi terrori dell'anno mille di cui siete tutti così sicuri ma è poi vero scusate che ci sono
stati and vogliamo andare a controllare vedere i cronisti di quegli anni cosa scrivevano cioè
in sostanza fare un po quello che io ho fatto stasera i primi che fanno queste cose non sono
spinti semplicemente non sono studiosi spinti dall'amore della verità ma sono anche combattenti
di una guerra il primo articolo che esce nel 1873 che parla in francia dei pretesi terrori
dell'anno mille e di un prete uno studioso ecclesiastico don plen per cui dimostrare che i
terrori dell'anno mille non ci sono mai stati non è soltanto un punto di precisazione storica
ma vuol dire dimostrare che han torto i laici e gli scienziati positivisti a parlare della
chiesa come di una fautore appunto della tenebra dell'ignoranza non è vero niente e qui devo
anche confessare che è molto imbarazzante questa faccenda per me perché io devo dire ho già detto
un po prima e lo dico di nuovo che tutto sommato sui due piatti della bilancia allora nelle
condizioni di allora aveva ragione i mangiapreti e aveva torto la chiesa la chiesa stava davvero
combattendo delle battaglie sbagliate contro tutto ciò che c'era di moderno il liberalismo la
democrazia l'unità d'italia ogni sorta di cose aveva ragione quegli altri per me però quegli
altri che avevano ragione per dimostrare che avevano ragione hanno costruito hanno fatto una
cattiva storografia hanno costruito una leggenda e ci hanno creduto i preti di pionono che difendevano
il vaticano forse più scurantista e reazionario che ci sia stato negli ultimi secoli però aveva
ragione e hanno fatto una storografia giusta e sono andati a scoprire la verità l'ultimissima cosa
che vorrei dirvi che prosegue questo discorso e lo attualizza ancora di più e che sembra era strano
ma non è ancora del tutto finita e cioè c'è ancora almeno in francia che è un paese dove
le spaccature ideologiche sono un po diverse dalle nostre ma sono profonde specialmente quella
fra cultura laica della repubblica e cultura cattolica c'è ancora oggi una qualche dimensione di
attualità in questa polemica sui terrori dell'anno mille e mi spiego è uscito da pochissimo tempo
un libro che fin dal titolo è chiaramente programmatico i falsi terrori dell'anno mille e di uno
studioso molto famoso in francia non ancora in italia che si chiama silvan gugenheim come la
Peggy gugenheim dell'arte contemporanea sarà quindi anche lui di origine ebraica vero similmente
ma è uno studioso cattolico che ha scritto questo libro molto militante i falsi terrori dell'anno
mille dicendo in sostanza questo è vero che i terrori dell'anno mille non ci sono stati ormai
lo sanno tutti ma non basta bisogna di si parla di più questa leggenda perché se andiamo a vedere
la storiafia del novecento la grande storiafia francese db quegli studiosi quando ci sono
occupati dell'anno mille dice gugenheim certo hanno ammesso che i terrori sono una leggenda ma
hanno molto insistito sul fatto che comunque c'era il millenarismo c'erano questi movimenti c'era
un'atmosfera pesante di in cui etudine in sostanza gugenheim attaccando alcuni mostri sacri della
storiafia del novecento come appunto jos db gugenheim dice questi in realtà grandi maestri per
carità però hanno creato di nuovo un'impressione falsa sono tornati a dare questa impressione
dell'anno mille come epoca tenebrosa inquieta oscura mentre dice gugenheim non è vero niente
perché è interessante scoprire questo perché gugenheim come vi dicevo è uno studioso non
solo cattolico ma arci cattolico ultra che è diventato famoso in francia non per questo libro
sui terrori dell'anno mille gugenheim è diventato famoso in francia per un libro che è uscito
cinque anni fa che si intitola aristotele al monsang michel il monsang michel avete presente
la famosa bazzia in normandia quella che sta in mezzo al mare quando c'è la marea rimane
isolata dalla terra ferma gugenheim in aristotele al monsang michel sostiene e dico sostiene perché
il suo libro ha provocato polemiche furibonde con illustri studiosi che hanno detto che è tutta
spazzatura e altri illustri studiosi che hanno detto che invece è molto interessante quindi io non
l'ho ancora letto riferisco soltanto quel che so in sintesi gugenheim in questo libro sostiene
di aver scoperto che nel monasterio del monsang michel nel medioevo c'era un grande centro
di traduzione dal greco in latino e lì si traduceva direttamente dal greco in latino
aristotele e tolomeo gli scienziati greci e così via io credo che voi capiate già le
implicazioni di questo ma gugenheim per non farsi mancar niente le esplicita nel suo libro
queste pagine le ho viste sono andato a vederle gugenheim dice e quindi non è vero quello che
ci hanno sempre raccontato che grazie agli arabi che noi abbiamo potuto possedere la filosofia e
la scienza greca la filosofia e la scienza greca dice gugenheim noi cristiani ce le siamo
tradotte direttamente dal greco e non avevamo nessun bisogno degli arabi e tanto per essere
ancora più chiaro nelle ultime pagine del libro gugenheim dice ed il resto si sa che l'arabo
è una lingua completamente inedatta per parlare di argomenti scientifici che gli arabi come mentalità
non sono un popolo di scienziati e di conseguenza era ridicolo pensare che noi dovessimo qualche
cosa alla cultura islamica e medievale noi non dobbiamo niente voi capite che è un argomento
un filino provocatorio e di fatti in francia ci sono stati i dibattiti furibondi su questo libro
ora capite colpisce che lo stesso studioso che scrive Aristotele al Monsa Michel il libro
successivo che scrive è per dire ricordiamo ce lo che i terrore dell'anno mille non ci sono mai
stati perché qui i laici c'hanno di nuovo un po' confuso le idee si parla troppo di
millenarismo medievale invece non è vero niente io qui non mi schiero i terrore non ci sono mai
stati questo è evidente chiarissimo è ma quello che mi interessava far vedere in conclusione è come
quali sono come sono complesse insomma le vie con cui si creano i miti e con cui poi rimangono
radicati magari si creano in modo del tutto innocente uno che ha aggiunto una righina in
una cronaca e magari rimangono lì silenziosi per secoli poi viene il momento in cui una certa
cosa torna utile nelle battaglie di quel momento e allora la si tira fuori e lo spirito critico
sparisce è un meccanismo estremamente impressionante per chi di voi ci sarà anche domani dopo
domani racconteremo esempi credo più divertenti di questo se io vuole di casi simili questo era
il primo questo avevo da raccontarvi stasera e quindi qui vi fermo grazie